alors philippe pascot je me tourne vers
vous une campagne pour le second tour
uniquement sur les réseaux sociaux et
dans les médias est ce que cela a pu
jouer est ce qu'elle a manqué la fameuse
poignée de main sur les marchés mais n'a
pas manqué du tout les gens ont des gens
faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des cons moi ce qui m'amuse beaucoup ce
soir c'est d'entendre pépère macro dire
qu'il est seulement préoccupés mais il
ya eu un électeur sur dix qui a été voté
pour le candidat vainqueur et dans sept
électeurs sur dix ils ont en marche a
pris une claque phénoménale et tout ce
que dit monsieur macron c'est qu'il est
préoccupé
ça prouve une fois plus que ces gens là
ne sont plus en phase avec la société ne
sont plus en scène il ya une fracture
entre eux et nous le peuple aujourd'hui
n'est pas la même chose que les
représentants le peuple aujourd'hui ne
représente pas les élus monsieur macro
et juste préoccuper le peuple ne s'est
pas déplacé pour voter mais il faut
absolument qu'ils fassent qui remettent
un masque sur sa tête qu'ils les
trouvent les masques ou qui du moins
qu'il l'enlève pour regarder la réalité
du terrain
moi je rejoins lexie aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes plus dans une démocratie
nous sommes dans une dans une société
qui petit à petit se dirige vers une
dictature quand je vois et vous me
confirmer que ya des candidats qui n'ont
même pas fini de compter les bulletins
et qu'ils passent devant la télé pour
dire je suis élu mais c'est un manque de
respect total par rapport aux électeurs
non seulement il ya eu très peu
d'électeurs qui se sont déplacés mais on
n'a même pas fini d'annoncer les
bulletins qu'on commence à faire le beau
à la télé mais c'est quoi cette
démocratie c'est juste une démocratie de
communication c'est juste une démocratie
de clientélisme
c'est juste une démocratie qui sert les
intérêts de quelques-uns de plus en plus
le peuple est mis sur le côté
de plus et le peuple malheureusement n'a
pas encore compris qu'il est le nombre
n'a pas encore compris que les patrons
c'est nous c'est pas eu pour l'instant
on au plie encore l'échiné et puis comme
de toute manière on sait pas où se
trouvait et bien malheureusement on va
pas voter mais moi je rejoins totalement
alexis
vous avez 60 % et je rappelle que les
60% n'est qu'un chiffre pondérer c'est à
dire qu on fait la moyenne de tous les
endroits et par exemple en corse il ya
eu 71 % de votants c'est vrai que là
quand ça la particularité d'arriver à
faire voter même les gens de 110 ans
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des endroits
où il ya eu plus de 70 80 % de gens qui
ne se sont pas déplacés pour voter
comment on peut encore dire que c'est
une élection
comment ces gens là aux dires mais
alexis le disait très bien quand vous
grattez un petit peu il ya plein de
barons locaux qui trouvent leur compte
quand je vois des vieux chevaux de
bataille qui se représentent et qui sont
élus c'est pas il n'y a pas un président
comment il s'appelle d'ailleurs ça
commence par un m
il a été lui remis en mai 2010 est
qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils allaient
moraliser la vie politique et j'entends
des élus qui se représente pour la
quatrième fois pour la cinquième fois à
l'est où cette moralisation aller où
cette loi qui disait qu'on peut pas se
présenter plus de trois mandats
ces gens-là nous mentent et maintenant
ils nous mentent officiellement alors
philippe pascot vous parliez tout à
l'heure de communication justement on a
vu le président de la république voté
avec un masque que tout comme edouard
philippe pendant le confinement souvient
aussi de ces images du président de la
république mais cette fois son masque
prendre des bains de foule des erreurs
de communication larve selon vous alors
messei fait du madoff en ce moment ils
sont dans la panique la plus totale et
ils font du n'importe quoi d'ailleurs la
plupart des images de communication de
ban foule que vous voyez à travers les
images qui sont dirigés quand on
retrouve ces mêmes images sur les
réseaux sociaux
mais au plan large et on s'aperçoit que
la foule allait pas nombreuses
je me rappelle d'une fois où il s'est
dirigé vers des gens vers une barrières
vauban en plan serré on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait 200 personnes
en plat en large
ils n'étaient que 50 c'est la panique
totale à l'elysée il se dit préoccupé
mais les staff autour de macro sont
complètement perdus qui font n'importe
quoi et on l'a bien vu comme sur la
façon dont ils ont géré la crise du
comique un coup les masques à coup les
vastes un coup pas les mascaras
aujourd'hui il ya eu une élection
municipale qui s'est passé les gens qui
sont élus nous
plus représentatif de la population
issia côte est élu le le pari des
républiques en marche ce clip parce que
c'était d'avoir dix mille représentants
locaux stanislas guérini affirme qu'il y
en a eu six mille au 1er tour vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
le pari de la république en marche et
d'avoir ses 500 élus pour pouvoir se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
je vous ai direct dix mille élus il les
a pas par contre c'est sûr qu'il aura
ses petits 500 élus parce que comme il
distribue des pièces et des piécettes
com heureusement pour la france entre
guillemets il ya un an je suis même pas
on peut dire heureusement on va changer
de premier ministre bientôt je sais pas
si c'est un bien je sais pas si à mal
mais j'arrive pas à comprendre que le
premier le premier ministre par exemple
se présentent au havre et que s'ils
restent premier ministre il a quand même
resté maire il va démissionner c'est
quoi ces gens là on est totalement dans
notre monde de l'apparence on est
totalement dans un monde où il nous
montre des choses et il faut la verse et
je dis bien ils font la verse
ces élections municipales aujourd'hui en
marche les a complètement foiré en
marche
et comme ils vont soirée la plupart des
autres élections ils vont maintenant
inventer des systèmes ou où vous allez
voir bientôt ils vont nous proposer le
vote électronique ça évitera aux gens de
se déplacer
je me tourne vers vous cette réaction là
quelques minutes de jordan bardella du
rassemblement national
il s'est félicité d'avoir fait voler en
éclats le front républicain le front
républicain qui apparaissait pour
beaucoup comme une évidence c'est fini
le alex il a dit c'est pas des front
républicain cd from clientélisme c'est
souvent l'alliance de la carpe et du
lapin
et puis les gens ne sont pas de vrais
dans le piège vous vous rendez compte
qu'à lille martine aubry s'est pas rendu
compte qu'en étant soutenu par un parti
de droite
à l'aller directement dans le mur ces
gens là sont encore dans un autre monde
non ne pourrai de lui qu'il n'existe pas
moi ce que j'aimerais carré d'as ray
c'est l'affront de citoyens et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui
rappelez vous écoutez bien ce que je lis
sur le 28 juin 2020 aucun grande
formation politique n'a dit qu'il
fallait repousser le culte à le
repousser le vote à cause du coc vide
parce que quelque part tous ces gens là
tous ces vieux politicards tous ces
vieux routard de la politique
ça les arrangeait qu'on continue à voir
les élections il savait déjà qu'il y
aurait un tripot taux d'abstention est
que grâce à ce très haut taux
d'abstention celui qui était un petit
peu connu sur sur le terrain celui qui
était un vieux cheval de retour et est
quasiment sûre d'être élu quand vous
voyez qu'il ya des monsieur copé
monsieur copé qui a été élu au premier
tour
pourquoi mais c'est la prime au sortant
ces élections municipales c'est ce que
va nous expliquer c'est c'est toujours
la prime aux sortants et en plus quand
vous faites du clientélisme comme ces
gens là le fond eh ben ils sont élus
quand il ya très peu d'électeurs vous
rendez compte que jolie et les endroits
où il ya eu 80 % de gens qui n'ont pas
été votées et il y avait quatre
candidats au deuxième tour
ces gens là ont beau être élu avec 1/2
électeurs sur 10 1/2 électeurs soliste
mais c'est un bonheur d'être élu de
faire des élections
d'ailleurs ils pensent vraiment à les
supprimer parce que à ce tarif là si ça
continue ils vont juste est élu avec
trois électeurs mais ça les arrange
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas pourquoi
monsieur maquereau a refusé de mettre le
bulletin blanc comme à bulletins
exprimés alors que c'était une demande
de 90% de la population
il y aurait peut-être eu un peu plus de
gens qui allaient voter mais il vole pas
il préfère dire qu'on va déclarer tout à
l'heure monsieur edouard philippe que si
vous n'allez pas voter c'est bien fait
pour vos pieds
mais il faut savoir que tous ces gens là
je dis bien tous ces gens là organisent
et sont d'accord ok de moins en moins de
gens qui aillent voter c'est malheureux
les gens suivent
philippe pascot jean luc mélenchon s'est
exprimé il y à quelques minutes et lui
il parle d'un moment dangereux après les
résultats de ce scrutin est ce que vous
partagez cette complètement
c'est un moment dangereux parce que
malheureusement comme le disait alexis
j'ai bien peur que les gens qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui les élus qui nous
représente ne comprennent pas dans quel
marasme ils sont est de plus en plus le
peuple risque de ne plus en avoir
dirt 2 plus rester calme et on se dirige
vers des choses assez grave aussi bien
vers les extrêmes que vers la descente
dans la rue vers l'explosion populaire
on n'arrête pas de crier 2
hurler il faut changer de système et ces
gens-là n'écoute pas sans gonce dans
leur bienséance s'engonce dans le fait
que ils font des choses pour le peuple
qui à la limite n'est pas assez
intelligent pour comprendre ce qu'ils
veulent pour nous vous vous rendez
compte en deux ans un petit plus de deux
ans on casse le code du travail on casse
la sécurité sociale on veut casser des
retraites au casque les élections
démocratiques et on continue à dire je
suis un petit peu préoccupé mais ces
gens là sont fous ils se rendent pas
compte que le peuple il ya 47 millions
d'électeurs
ils sont ils m'ont avoir lu à peine 4
millions de personnes qui ont été
utilisés lisent ils se rendent pas
compte qu'ils sont curieux liza minnelli
et qui a mené ça va se savoir
je le répète et je le dis ces gens là
aujourd'hui sont élus mais ne sont plus
représentatifs de la population
et quand vous êtes plus représentatif de
la population la population commence à
se lever et à se dire et à dire stop
stop arrêtez arrêtez de nous étouffer
arrêter de nous deux nous martyriser
arrêter de nous empêcher de nous
exprimer parce que ils vont pas avoir
d'autres solutions pépère macro ne va
pas avoir d'autre solution que de
resserrer la vis resserrer la vis sur
plein de choses vous allez voir dans
l'es8 dans les mois qui suivent de moins
en moins on pourra parler de moins en
moins pour un tir parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eu d'autre choix
ils représentent que rien